Good afternoon. I'm Vic, one of your
interpreters. I'm going to make a quick
announcement in Spanish for those that
may need or want interpretation into
Spanish.
There's anyone that needs interpretation
devices. They're over to the left.
And while they're doing that, we're
going to go ahead and get started. I
know we have some parents that needed to
drop their students off, so we're
probably going to have people that
dwindle in, and that will be fine. Uh,
welcome. My name is Roa Coleman. I'm the
principal here at Palm. I'm proud. proud
principal here at Palm.
Thank you all so much for being here.
Um, I do realize that it's immediately
after school and it wasn't the most
convenient time, but it was the best
time that we could find to be able to
have the team here. So, we'd like to
welcome you. Um, just a few quick
reminders as we before we get started.
We do have child care in the gym. Coach
Anderson and Miss Gomez, our PE team are
in the gym. They have games set up. They
have movies. They have snacks. So, if
you'd like for your child to go to child
care, that is an option for you. Also,
facilities to the right. We do have
restrooms um for everyone. They're open.
So you if you need to take care of any
of your needs or anything, you can go
right over there to the restrooms. And
um we're going to go ahead and get
started. I'd like to again welcome you.
Thank you. And to Superintendent Matias
and your team, thank you so much for
being here. Thank you for coming to
listen to answer our questions. Um we do
have about 90 minutes for this meeting.
So I'm going to go ahead and turn it
over to Miss Ally and she will
facilitate the rest of the meeting.
Thank you so much, Principal Coleman.
Hello everyone. My name is Ally
Gillarduchi. I am the senior executive
director of communications and community
engagement. I just want to review our
agenda. So, we just had our welcome.
We're going to go over some meeting
norms and the purpose of this meeting so
we're all on the same page. We'll
introduce some of the folks that we have
here to help answer questions along with
our superintendent. Um, we want to
provide an overview. probably everyone's
relatively familiar with what is in the
current recommended plan, but we just
want to make sure that it's really clear
to everyone here what we're recommending
and kind of the rationale why. If y'all
have questions about why this was the
recommendation, we'll be having that
conversation. Um, then we also want to
be able to respond to some of the
questions that were submitted in the
comment card. So, we pulled out
questions that y'all your community
submitted in advance to the comment card
and we're going to start by addressing
those before we get into a bigger
conversation. Um, and then we'll talk
about next steps and that will be it.
Um, going over the meeting norms. We,
and I know this is pretty small font,
but we are here to build the future
together. We want to acknowledge the
challenges of the situation that we're
in while focusing on ideas and solutions
that make our district stronger, more
equitable, and sustainable for years to
come. Um, we want to honor time. So,
we're going to try to ask that if you're
speaking that you try to limit your
comments to a minute. And we're going to
try to keep our responses brief enough
so that there's space for everyone. Um,
we want to honor the process, um, which
just means following along with the
agenda, um, so that we can get to hear
from everybody. Um, honor, intent, and
impact. We may disagree on ideas, but we
want to assume positive intent and focus
on our shared goal, which is having
strong, equitable schools for all
students. Um, we're going to honor space
and voice. That means if you do speak
once, we're going to ask that we let
everyone else that's interested in
speaking speak before we have you speak
a second time. Um, we want to try to
stay solution oriented. So, focusing on
ideas, solution, understanding as
opposed to blame or frustration. And
lastly, we are here um to embrace um and
demonstrate empathy. We know these are
difficult conversations um but we're
going to meet them with compassion,
clarity, and honesty. And that's our
commitment to y'all.
Um so the purpose of today's meeting, um
much much like what we said in the
agenda is that we want to make sure that
we respond to some of those frequently
asked questions that you already let us
know that were on your mind when you
first saw the draft plan. Um, we want to
gain a shared understanding of what is
proposed and why. Um, and then we as a
leadership team want to gain insights
into any of your thoughts and ideas that
could inform potential refinements to
the plan, things that we can
incorporate. Um, we are going to have a
revised version of the plan this Friday.
Um, and that's going to be directly
reflective of the things that we heard
in the comment cards that we are able to
incorporate. Um, and the final draft is
in it will be going before the board
November 20th. And with that, I'm going
to pass it over to our superintendent to
give an introduction.
>> Yeah, thank you, Ally. Um,
I very much appreciate all of y'all um
coming out this afternoon and having a
conversation. Uh, as Ally said, this is
a draft plan. We are refining it. It's
really, really important that we get
input from our community uh as we take
the next step. And I I want to also
acknowledge just how disruptive this is.
Uh it's not lost on me that these types
of changes are very challenging to move
through as a community. It's it's hard.
It's sad. Um I just want to apologize
that we're having to go through that at
this moment. It's never something I ever
thought I would have to do uh as a
superintendent. It's not something um I
ever wanted to do.
The reality is that in Austin ISD,
we have some schools that get what they
need and we have strong neighborhood
schools in certain parts of Austin. But
the reality is that we do not have
strong schools everywhere.
And it's also true that for the last 144
years, as we have grown to be who we
are, decision after decision after
decision has been made. And we're at a
point where students who look like me,
students that look like me, the students
here at Palm haven't gotten what they've
needed to be successful. That's just the
honest truth.
The board and I are very much aligned in
that every student should get what they
need. Period. And every student has a
different need.
Now to do that, we have to think about
how we work, what resources we have, and
be honest about what's changed.
And we have to do all of it in this
moment when public education, as we see
it, is being challenged at every corner
along the way.
And so our goal is to have strong,
vibrant, loving neighborhood schools
so that every student has access to
them. Right? And what do we mean by
thriving or loving? Well, we want
students to, you know, love learning,
not just be good about taking a test. We
want students to feel comfortable in
their own skin.
We want students to view being bilingual
or having or being bicultural,
multicultural as a superpower. And to do
that, we have to think about the
resources that we have as a school
district.
And so this plan that we have addresses
all of it in a very
complex multi-layered strategy.
Right? The first thing that it attempts
to do is to align feeder patterns.
And when I talk about aligning feeder
patterns, I want our elementary school
students to go to no more than one or
two middle schools. Keep community
together, keep families together, and
then have middle schools go to no more
than one or two high schools.
Right now in Austin, we have middle
schools that go to four and five high
schools.
Can you guess where those schools are?
They're in East Austin.
We also have lots of schools that go
100% into the middle school or high
school, and you can guess where those
schools are.
So, this plan aims to realign feeder
patterns throughout the city of Austin.
Lots of boundary changes, but ultimately
we want to keep community together. We
want to align programming and if we do
it, we believe that we'll be in a better
position long term. Two,
the cost of education has gone up year
over year for the last many, many years.
The state hasn't helped in the way that
I believe that they should have.
Changes at the federal level have
impacted title two, title three, and
title four funds.
We have to pay our educators to give
them a chance to be able to live in this
community. We've made investments the
last three years in a row in
compensation and we're going to continue
to do that.
But as we do that, it puts stress on our
system, right? Because everything costs
money.
So to become more efficient, we have to
think about where we have misalignments
in our school system. And to do that, we
have to think about consolidations,
boundary changes, and this plan
considers that. Three,
program alignment.
Dual language is something that we
believe in in Austin.
There are school districts around
Central Texas who are moving away from
it. Not us, not our board, not our
administration. We are leaning into it.
But to do it well, you have to ensure
that the program is focused on the
students that it was intended for,
emergent bilingual students.
And right now, we have programs that are
not balanced. In order to balance them,
we need to move them where our students
are, our emergent bilingual students.
And this plan does that.
The other thing that we have to consider
is that we are in an accountability
system at the state level that's bigger
than our school district.
I will never ever ever say that these
letters that are given to our schools
represent who our schools are.
Right? The state does that. They're the
ones that assign Fs and D's and C's and
A's and B's on a single assessment. take
on a single day in most cases.
And the reality of all of all of it is
that I have to ensure that we as a
system move through that and break these
accountability chains. And we'll talk
more about that in a moment. But if we
don't if we don't address these real
risks that come with accountability,
we potentially lose the ability of
educating our students the way that we
believe locally. Your trustees
get to determine the direction that we
go in as a school district. They are
local locally elected. And so for us,
this plan also has to consider the
accountability risk that exists in
Austin ISD. If we do not own it, if we
do not move the system, then at some
point in the future, this district could
look very, very different. And we're not
going to let that happen. I won't let
that happen. So this plan includes it.
The other thing that this plan includes
are transfer policy changes
in Austin. There have been many policies
that have been in place for decades that
have moved students from one part of the
city to another part of the city, right?
Or that the control of the transfer has
been at the school level, not at the
district level. That creates inequities.
Why is it that you have so many students
that are choosing to leave the East
Austin a east side early college high
school vertical and go to Austin High?
Right. So, this plan is considering all
of it. It is a lot. Um, and we will have
those conversations with you. Uh and we
need to move forward as a school system
because
one of the things that we cannot do is
not acknowledge this real risk that
exists as a school system
and
kick the can down the road. Because the
one thing I cannot take away from our
staff or our families is time to plan. I
am someone that will give you that time.
I'm someone that will make a hard
decision, but I'm not going to be more
disruptive than I have to be. Um, and so
let's talk about what this means for
Palm. So, Palm Elementary School, uh, I
know Palm Mill, you have an incredible
principal and, uh, Miss Coleman wrote
has been, she's incredible. Y'all have
done incredible things. Y'all have, uh,
performed year-over-year.
Uh the reality of it all is that there
are simply not enough students that live
here now that used to live here. And so
if we took all the students in this area
and assumed that every one of them came
to Palm, we would still not get close to
filling up the school. And so when we
think about how as a system we get to
become uh more balanced and provide the
resources, we can't have huge
inefficiencies.
And so the plan includes Palm Elementary
School going wholly into Pettas
Elementary School. If you can go back to
that slide real quick. Uh the reason
that's important is because any time
that we can keep community together,
we're going to do it right. We don't
want to break up Palm Elementary School.
We don't want to send the school to
multiple schools. We want to keep the
school and the community together. This
allows us to do that.
The other thing I want to point out um
and we'll talk about more about this in
a little bit is uh staffing. I
want our community and staff to know
that any transition, any disruption is
something that is very centered at our
work. Um I have committed over and over
again that those who want to be in
Austin will have a home. I've I've been
clear about it. there's been like some
messages out there about Matias is going
to do this. That is not true. That is
not true at all. Uh so as we move
forward because of what we're talking
about in this specific plan, there's
actually a lot more flexibility than you
might have in other plans per let's say
a school that was going through a
turnaround plan or a school that was
going through a programmatic move. So
we'll have those conversations with
staff. Um, but I want our our community
to know that I recognize that the only
reason I exist is to support our
educators in the classroom. That's it.
Now, um, this plan, as we'll talk about
here, uh, includes, um, this beginning
in the next school year, which means
that we'll spend the rest of this
semester and all of next semester
planning, preparing, working between
both school communities to develop a
healthy, thoughtful transition. uh and
then we'll um implement the board vote
will not occur till November 20th. Um
but we were wanting to hear from you all
today, have a conversation and talk
about what things you know we need to
consider as we move forward. You want to
go through some of the questions?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, we have a few of the questions
that were submitted in advance that
we're going to go through. Um, starting
with this one from Ricardo A. This
school is a vital part of our community
and shutting it down would disrupt
students, break important relationships
with teachers, and create longer, more
difficult commutes. Has the district
explored other options, and can it delay
the decision to close schools?
>> Yeah. So,
we have looked at lots of options
um over the last uh many months, but
even years prior as part of the long
range plan. And the reality is that we
just don't have the students that live
here. Uh and so in order to stabilize
the community, we need to create a big
enough area to fill up a school and to
have all of our resources supporting
those students. Could we delay? Um we
could. Uh I am not going to propose
that. And here's the reason.
We are facing a budget deficit. We are
facing transition moves. We're facing
accountability risks. All these things
cost resources. They do. They really,
really do. And so, if we're going to do
all of it together,
the strategy and the approach should be
to do it all together at once so that we
as a system are taking the steps in
unison. any one of these getting pulled
out um you know just means that that
risk over the next year uh will increase
because I will not propose a plan change
in the spring semester because of what
we talked about. If you do something in
the spring, it's harder for our staff to
to be supported. Our families don't get
the information they need to prepare for
the school year. It creates lots of
confusion. We've seen that happen.
Mendes and Martin had sixth grade pulled
out in 2023.
That was done in April.
The school district scrambled. Our
families scrambled and we had about a
month and a half, two months to try to
get it together and it never really
worked
because I have to implement the plan and
I do not want to fail or to to do
something that is not in alignment with
you all's expectations. And so my uh
strategy and my approach is we take a
vote together in November. We have time
to plan. If there is a delay, it is in a
out year. Uh and at that point, you
know, all the other things that we're
trying to avoid risk-wise would actually
grow. Um so that is why uh we're not
looking at a delay at this point or at
least I am not.
>> Um the next question is multi multiple
commenters brought this one up. So, if
Palm closes, would Langford continue to
reside in its current location in the
portables or will Langford Yeah. will
Langford students continue to attend
classes in the portables located at Palm
while Palm's building is vacant?
>> Yeah. So, um right now this is one of
those transition questions that we will
refine. Um, but I can tell you that if
Palm uh were to close in the 26 27
school year and the building was vacant,
we would look to see if there was an
opportunity to reduce the costs of
actually keeping Langford in the
portable city, right? Because that's
also a cost. So, anytime we collectively
can drive down our costs, I'd like to
explore it. And it's always good to have
kids in buildings opposed to portables.
So, I can't say for certain that it's
going to be all of this or all of that
as far as in Langford or in Palm or in
the portables, but I can say that we
would be looking to figure out um a an
interim kind of uh swing space solution
that drives costs down because it it
would be I would I would think uh a
disservice to our students in the
portables if they're right outside a
school building. Uh but again that will
go through and we'll work through that
with the community as part of the
transition plan.
>> The next question was from Reanetta A.
Have you considered combining Langford
and Palm? Um and then what is the
thought process behind Palm being
reassigned to Bettz and not Blazier
>> and why did the district choose to close
Palm instead of changing the boundaries
of Blazer and Palm? Those are multiple
people ask that.
>> Interesting. So can you go to the map
real quick? So we have looked at um Palm
into Lenford. One of the things that I
want our families and staff to know is
that Bettis is actually in between,
right? So whenever you look at
boundaries, you really want to have them
continuous. And so like when you can see
right here, this is Pettis, right?
>> This is Palm and this is Lenford. So, in
order to connect the two, we would have
to create this really kind of weird
shape through the park or we would have
to create a broken attendance boundary.
Uh, which is not something we would want
to do. Uh, and it would also include
significant um I would say logistics
challenges when it comes to
transportation. The preferred approach
is always going to be to take two
adjacent attendance boundaries and merge
them, which is what we're proposing
here. We did look at it. Um I will also
say that uh Langford is um full
relatively full and so we would not be
able to relocate all of Palm. And one of
the things that we really felt strongly
is that we wanted the community to stay
together. So, um, that is, you know, I
think one of the tradeoffs where we
could explore that further, but I want
our community to know that it's likely
to be a really small percent of the
existing students at Palm that actually
would fit into Langford. Um, the other
question was
>> also
>> Blazier. So Blazer's to the south and
what makes these schools challenging is
that they're on the edge of AISD's
attendance boundary and Palm is not too
far from Blazier. Blazier is just to the
south and so it's you cannot easily you
cannot change the attendance boundary of
Blazier because the closest area is
actually the area that includes the
school and so we never want to be in a
situation where the school is not in the
attendance boundary that supports it.
Right? Right. So, look at see where
Blazer is.
>> So, Blazer's here. I'm sorry. I'll walk
to that one. Blazier's here, right? Just
to the south. And but Blazier goes all
the way down to Creedmore. And so, if
Palm was to just move over just six or
seven streets, it would begin to be
inside the attendance B. It would begin
to consume what is Blazer. And we can't
do that, right? You the school needs to
be in the attendance boundary. So this
is a function of just the locations
decisions that were made years and years
and years ago. Um there's not an easy
solution because we're bound on the east
side with you know really Del Valley and
outside the area. So anything else you
want to add to that Christine?
>> Yes, thank you. Um Christine Steampport,
operations officer for Austin ISD. And I
just wanted to add to what you said,
Superintendent Sigura. When we look at
schools and we look at boundaries, we
start with where our students live and
we want to make sure that right we're
having those neighborhood schools. But
when we looked in this cluster of an
area and we do this all over with our
boundaries in the process, we have about
5600 seats between about six to seven
schools, but we only have 3,900
students. So that's where we start
looking at where our schools are
situated as he was just kind of
mentioning. and also how how much
occupancy capacity do we have in that
school that's comfortable and that's a
healthy what we call a healthy
utilization. And so that's kind of where
we really started from that place of
looking at our locations where our
schools are and looking where our
students live and then looking at how
many seats we have available in those
areas. So
>> Oh yes. And I think that there was a
question about Blazier fitting all of
Palm. It's just not possible. Um it's a
very Yeah. Uh, and it's a that area is
is being developed more, but the the
projections are still at a high
utilization.
>> The Good Night Ranch development that
has thousands of single family homes, as
I know you all are aware of, is just
putting all that pressure in that area
um to increase the I know you you have a
Ally, any questions? You want us We can
>> I think
>> Yeah, go ahead.
>> Yeah, if you have a follow-up, I can
bring you the mic.
>> Yeah.
So I live in the community as well as
work here at Palm and I'm literally one
block away from Blazier. So the kids in
the next blocks go to Blazer. The kids
on my street go to Palm. My question is
I've seen y'all reszone the other areas
kind of wonky. So I don't understand the
justification that we can't send Blazier
kids to Palm when you know I live on a
street a couple of blocks that are Palm.
Right next door is Blazer. Why can't we
get the kids that are north of Blazier,
which is Saxon Place, plus east of
Blazer, which is Mckini Heights, and
send them over to Palm? Because
Slaughter Lane is still being developed
with homes and neighborhoods. So, in
five years, you're going to have Blazia
that's already full. It's going to be
busting at the seams. And what are you
going to do then? In five years, you're
going to make another school.
>> So, the So, um, so we looked at that.
The challenge is how many school
so remember you're the school as a whole
is less than 50% filled right so the
question becomes how would that even
come close to filling up the students
would it come close to actually um
getting us to where we would have a
healthy stable utilization um my
understanding and based when I was going
through the work you'd have to go pretty
far into Blazier's attendance boundary
to make up the difference Um, I can't
I'm guess I know the I'm very familiar
with this area. I'm trying to think
through which streets I can't speak off
hand. I can provide that data, but when
we looked at it, it was a pretty
significant number because a lot of that
area, especially to the north of Blazer,
as you all know, it's you have the park
area. It's a big area, but there's lots
of park space, open space there, too.
So, you have to go pretty far down into
that area before you get to pick up
enough students that would fill up. So,
if it's a couple streets, perhaps that's
dozens, but I don't know that it's
hundreds and hundreds, which is really
what we need to be thinking about to
actually fill up Palm, but we're happy
to to to look at that and to provide
more feedback. But that's the the
approach that we took and why.
>> And I also wanted to touch to a little
bit of your comment earlier about
projections. We are looking at 10 years
projections with birth rate, census
data, developers, all of that with the
city. Um, and so this is projected 10
years out. We always like to really hone
in on five, but this has projections as
well. And if you look at the bottom of
that boundary map, you'll see those
projections specifically for 2029, which
gives us a good average after maybe
there's some grandfathering policies
that students are able to do to kind of
give you that showcase of what it would
look like and how that school could be
utilized.
>> Um, I'm going to go back and forth
between because I want to make sure we
get to the questions that were
presented. Is this kind of related to
Isl?
>> Yeah. Well, I hope it's related to
Blazer. I'm in the wrong meeting.
>> So, no one is arguing that Palm is not
close to Bettis. What we're saying is
you're saying that we can't pull some of
those kids because it would be pulling
some of the kids that are in that
attendance boundary. Correct. From from
from Blazer. You said we can't pull kids
from Blazer because then we're going
into Blazers the the kids are close to
Right. Well, we you don't want to have
the palm boundary go so far south that
it's actually around Blazer proper.
>> But what you do want is for the parents
here to pass Palm to go to Pettis.
And we don't see how that's fair. You
see what I'm saying? You're you're
telling like and and when you think
about it like Langford might come into
this building because you could imagine
them being over there with this vacant
building, but then you want parents who
live right here to pass this school
where Langford might be in next year for
them to drive past their what was
originally their home school to go to
Pettis now when we could just get some
of those Pettis kid those Blazer kids to
come here. But because no one for some
reason doesn't want to mess with Blazer
because of the numbers set boundaries
whatever it is. I I I have no it's
that's not true. I I I we will look at
all solutions and refine. It was never
about not wanting to do something. It's
just
>> what what large enough area actually
creates a healthy student population for
the next 10 years that would support us.
>> And and to us, I mean, as a as a
community here, we've all talked about
it is bringing us some of Blazer because
Blazer has exploded. That's why you
built that other school. And meanwhile,
we were just dwindling down, especially
when we had the flood that took all
those houses and took those families.
So, if we would have gotten some of
those families in the beginning, if
those boundaries would have been changed
a long time ago, we wouldn't be in this
situation. And there's no reason why we
can't get those kids to come here. It's
easier for those Blazer kids to come
down the street for it than for these
beds. I mean, these palm parents to go
all the way to bed is most of our
parents walk. Okay. So, I mean that I
don't understand. And I don't and when I
sit here and hear you say, "Oh, these
are closed." We understand that. That's
not hard for anyone here to understand.
What we don't understand is why you
can't get Blazer kids to come here.
>> They also don't have
>> correct.
So, I mean, I So, we're happy to to
continue to to refine. I mean, I I think
um the one question uh that I just want
to be really clear about is how many
students we actually need to pull in
order to make that work. And I just that
because that's the question, right?
Because a couple streets in my
experience is doesn't solve the problem,
right? It is a huge area that typically
is needed to and it's not just who lives
there, it's how many actually go to that
school. So we look at live-in, we look
at projections, but we and so we could
look at that. We we have the analysis.
I'm not prepared to share kind of how
far down you have to go. Um and as far
as wonky boundaries, I'm not sure who I
think that was you, ma'am. Um like we're
trying to get away from that. That's one
of the thing. That's why we're in some
of these messes that we're in now
because for the last 144 years, a road
would get expanded or this school would
get added and then we would create this
little boundary and we'd want to protect
this thing. And so that's kind of how we
got to where we are. I do not want to
just do what others have done if it
doesn't make sense for our community.
Now, if we say here, okay, let's if
Langford had a room, right? Let's say
they had a room and we could make it
work. You would see me wanting to figure
out a way to make it work. That's what
I'm trying to hear from you all is
Matias. This is we understand the
environment we're in. It sounds like
there's consensus around that. I am
trying to figure out how I can make an
adjustment work to support community
need acknowledge this pain that we're in
and the stress that we're in and we're
happy to look at that. I mean, we we are
happy to look at that. I just don't want
to set the expectation that we can all
of a sudden just go down blazer a couple
streets and then it's going to solve
this the problem. That may not be the
case. And so I just that's that's maybe
my counterposition. not
>> and and I appreciate your comment about
the boundaries because we've heard that
from other schools. Nobody changes the
boundary. There's no regular review
process. The a city of Austin has
changed drastically, but then there's
been we build a new school, but we don't
look at the boundaries and try to
balance that way. And so, I think this
is our first approach, right? We don't
want to get in this situation that we've
been in for years, honestly decades. Um,
we want to have a regular review
boundary process to where we're doing
this every two to three years. That's
what other districts do near us. I mean,
Liberty Hill, they're growing and
Leander and they have usually something
every year just because they're
expanding so much, but we have to do the
same thing so we don't get into the same
problem that we have now. So, I
appreciate your comment.
>> I'm going to take the next question from
the comment card and then I saw you had
your hand up, so I'll go to you after
that. Um, so the next question was,
"Tffic William Cannon is a concern. Can
you explain if transportation will be
provided for students who are reszoned?
>> So our transportation policy would be
the same. So if you live more than 2
miles from the school where you are
zoned to attend, then you would have
transportation or if the route is deemed
hazardous that if it's walkable or
bikable, we would also provide a bus um
for that student.
>> Okay. Sorry, I'm gonna ask a question
for a parent. So what is the answer to
that?
>> So yes, you will get a bus. You will get
a bus.
>> So uh I'm a transfer mother from Kyle.
Um how would that work for our kids? I
know a lot of our kids are don't belong
to Austin, but we did the proper
transfer. How would that work for them?
>> Yeah. So,
>> so that's one of the things that we're
addressing as part of this update um in
our plan to be really really clear
because we want our families who've
transferred into the school, if they
choose to go with the school, they can
go with the school. Um and so that's
that's one of the things that wasn't
clear in the initial draft and honestly
it wasn't clear because there were just
so many scenarios that we had to work
through to make sure we we addressed it
correctly. So, in the new version, we're
going to have a whole document that's
set aside for transfer policies and
standard operating procedures. And what
you're going to see in that is students
who transfer into a school will be kept
by way of the superintendent and board
adoption of the policy with the cohort
of the school. So, if if your student
goes to Palm now and the entire cohort
of students goes to Betz, you would have
the ability to go to to beta transfer
automatically approved. Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah. Um, so, so that's what we're doing
to try to limit any of these kind of,
you know, these things that are not
consistent with our values. We want that
for you. We want that.
>> Okay. And my next question is reiterate
again if I'm I'm going to say it and
correct me if I'm wrong. Why can't we
transfer I mean, why can't we combine
Langford and Palm?
>> So, I'm sorry.
>> Okay. It wouldn't fit. Okay. So well
yeah Palm going to when you say combined
I was trying to figure out you talking
about here or there because L Palm
cannot fit in Langford being rebuilt
>> because Palm I mean because Langford has
the amount of students they have right
correct. Yeah
>> but Pettis has the same amount of
students and you're fitting our kids
over it's going to be the same amount of
students. So help me understand that.
>> So each school has a different capacity.
So not all schools have the same size
fit the same number of students. Um and
just look at this school and Blazer
right? They're very very different. Um,
Blazer is much larger. So when we think
about what it takes to fill up, we think
about, well, how many students are there
now and then how many students can fit
safely and support the academic
programming. And what we know is that
Bettz has space when you think about it
from that perspective. Um, I don't
recall like the capacity of each school,
but every school does have a different
capacity.
>> Okay. I have another question, but I
will ask that way you can move on.
>> Okay. Yeah. And I'll be here. Well, I I
also want to know like I feel like our
teachers are overflowing with students.
I I remember I there used to be less
amount of students. Our teachers have
like over 20 students in their class
sometimes.
What I just want to know how this is
going to benefit our kids. You keep
talking about budget and budget and
budget. It's going to benefit you guys,
but how is it going to benefit our kids?
>> So, when you say so, the the one thing I
will say is um by state requirements,
right? It's 22 students is the maximum
we can have for in an elementary
classroom. So 22.
>> Okay. Some of yours last year had more
than 22.
>> No, no, I'm I'm giving you I want to
give you like kind of concept because
there's a you made you said a comment
around budget concerns us like the one
of the things you run into is we don't
have educators in our classrooms the way
we need to have them. We have vacancies,
right? We have to provide the resources
for your students, the curriculum,
instructional coaches, content
interventionists, all those things to
make sure that your student is on grade
level and getting what they need in
alignment with our values. So, so, so I
guess the word I'm saying is budget is a
huge part of this, but it's not the
reason we make decisions. Everything is
in service to the classroom. That's the
reason we exist. But if I don't have the
funds to actually support our educators
and your students, then everybody, all
of our students, all of our schools are
not going to be successful. That's just
the honest truth. And right now, I mean,
we've we've been the federal government
made changes. We lost $16 million 11
million overnight, right? That's huge.
The cost of education has gone up. We're
running about a, you know, four, well,
we cut a hund00 million last in the last
two years in our budget and we're trying
to find more funds wherever we can and
trying to stay away from the classroom.
We have decided to protect certain
things. We've decided to keep librarians
in our schools, right? That's something
that's above and beyond what the state
has. We've decided to have nurses.
That's something above and beyond what
the state requires. We've decided to be
able to procure our own um uh
curriculum. We could have a different
curriculum and save $6 to8 million, but
I promise you that curriculum is not
going to align with our values. And so I
just want to be really clear like
everything is tied to resources. It's
not that I I am thinking about it only
from a finance perspective, but the
reality of it all is if we cannot have a
healthy fund balance, if we cannot pay
our educators, the risk from the agency
and for our ability to support our
teacher, I mean support our students is
is real. Um, so that's how they're
connected. So, I just want you to know
it's all
>> the next question is actually really
connected to this, so you might want to
stay on that track, but it says, "How
will closing 13 schools impact
enrollment and overall resources for the
district?"
>> Yeah. So, um, one of the things that we
hear from time to time is, uh, if you go
through a school consolidation process,
you're going to lose students, right?
Um, one of the other things that I I've
seen is that we have schools right now
who've historically been underserved.
Uh, and they're not um the choice for
many of the students in the
neighborhood. So, you can think about
where that is. Where do we have areas in
Austin where there are lots of students,
but they're not selecting our schools?
Well, why is that? A lot of it comes
down to because there are families that
feel as though the charter school or the
school next door is the better option or
the school across town.
So I want to desperately get to a place
where all of our schools are high
performing, right? Not only how we see
see it, but our state sees it, but we
actually have the resources to do it.
And I can't do that with 116 schools and
a budget that has been going in the
wrong direction. Uh and the other thing
that puts additional pressure on it is
enrollment. I mean, our enrollment has
declined in the last many years. And
it's not that our proportion of all the
students has changed. It's that there
are families who cannot afford to live
in Austin. They just they can't. And so
they're moving out. And we've seen that
over the last 10 years. And that is
directly how we get like funding from
the state. So all these things have
gotten us to a point where we have to
think about okay if we're going to do
something well and have strong
neighborhood schools we have to
acknowledge that we may have to have
fewer of them to do it well. That's just
the honest truth.
>> Thanks. We have a question right here.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I want to get back to the
transportation talk. Yeah.
>> So we live within walking distance. All
of our children come here. There's
several uh families in the community
here at Palm uh who have disabilities
who utilize special transit services.
So, we've checked and there is no school
bus for our students to get to Parees
and I am at work at 5 a.m. My wife works
on the other end of Austin. So, we would
have to be dropping our students off at
like 6:00 6:30 in the morning just so we
can my wife can get to work on time or I
would totally have to find another job
or means of work to accommodate dropping
them off. What is the resolution for
that?
>> Yeah. So, the first thing I would say is
there wouldn't be a bus just yet because
this plan hasn't like they're they're
not connected yet. So, our
transportation system would not have
created a bus route until they merge
together and become one attendance
boundary. Uh, as Christine said, if
you're over two miles, you will
automatically get a bus. And if there's
any hazardous route, and William Cannon,
I would argue, is a hazardous route. So,
anything beyond I mean, right, I mean, I
live on William Cannon. I grew up off
William Cannon. I know it well. Uh, so
so that that will address itself. We can
be clear and in the policy changes in
the plan kind of show you what it will
look like. um we didn't clearly
articulate it in the first draft because
it's part of our policy already but we
so we couldn't show it in that way but
we will we'll make it very very clear.
The other thing is this is what is
helpful if we understand that this
community needs a different level of
support early in the morning at any of
the receiving schools like we the
district with board support can make
those changes. We have families all
across the city that we have 20,000
students that use our buses. We have
some schools that open up really really
early with programming where they have
partners in place. We have students that
come and some just rest in the morning
because their families are working two
and three jobs. Like we understand that,
but I need to know like what needs to
change in the combined or the new school
to support you. That that is what this
is is going to be about once we get past
these votes is transition planning,
transition planning, transitions
planning. The last thing I want is for
any one of our families to feel like
they have to do something different to
support their student. Like that's our
job. I have to change. Um, so that's how
we're going to tackle it. And one of the
documents that you're going to see in
our next upload this Friday is our
framework for transition. So you'll see
all the things that we're considering as
we get through this work. How do you
bring PTAs together? How do you you
know, what's the um the approach that
we're going to use to honor the legacy
of the um the school that's being
vacated. All of those things will be in
there. Uh and also programming. If
there's programming that's not there now
that needs to be there, we will address
it. The last thing is special education
transportation. Um we provide
transportation for any student that
receives special education services.
Period. Right? That's a period. So um if
that were the case, you can feel
confident that we would provide that
transportation. It is a separate system.
It's not tied to board policy. It's
actually tied to um state and federal um
policy. So that would not be a concern.
We would get that one taken care of if
that was a a question. And the next
question that was presubmitted, actually
this came up with multiple commenters,
is about special education. Um, and I
might call Christa up here to help out
with this one. Um, but it says, "Our
students receiving special education
services are excelling and seeing a
improvement here at Palm. What
considerations are being given for
students receiving special education
services through this transition to
happen?
>> Thank you. Hi, my name is Christa
Ethridge. I'm the interim executive
director of special ed. Um and we
certainly want to continue to see our
students um to improve and excel. Um
good news is that Bettas offers a very
offers a very robust special education
program. Um they offer a full continuum
of supports and services. So um we're
not anticipating that there will be any
disruption to services and that that
will continue to um flow as it is now.
>> Yeah. Yeah, the one thing I would say is
in the plan that you'll see on this
Friday, we also have a separate document
that is specifically to spe students
receiving special education services and
what our students can expect as we
transition, you know, when the AR would
take place if there's not a service at
that school. In some cases, maybe
there's life skills at the school that
the student is at but not at the
receiving school. Like what's our plan
there? So, we're going to be very very
intentional. Um we're thinking through
all the different elements but the
support for special education and the um
resources allocated come out of special
education department. They do not come
out of talent and strategy because we
place based on need not based on the
number of students if that makes any any
sense. So that's why it's kind of
important that we talk about both them a
little bit separately when it comes to
staffing. But that's how we're going to
tackle it. There'll be more detail on
the plan.
>> So I want to go back to Langford. Um, I
was passing by and Langford is just a
hole in the ground. There's there's no
building right now. And you were saying
that Langford and Palm together here
wouldn't have capacity. But before the
floods, P Langford has like, I think,
450 kids. We have like 3 something.
Together, they could fit here. We used
to have more than that before the floods
took our students away. So, um, I don't
understand like why that wouldn't work.
there's no school there. You get rid of
the portables, you keep this school, put
some resources into it, sell that
property over there, and we have a
robust school here, and the parents are
still in their community, right?
>> So,
so we'd be doing the opposite to
Langford, right?
>> So,
>> yeah. Well, it's actually not quite that
long. Um but the one of the things I
would say is um bond allocations, the
projects, like all of those things. Uh
you know, modernized facilities, that is
something the district and I am we're
committed to progressing. Um I'm
certainly happy to add more detail as to
kind of how that plays into it. Um I I I
don't want to kind of just say that we
would do that um without kind of more
intentional.
>> Yeah. the
>> well so the way that the bond dollars
work and I want to be really really
clear uh bond dollars um can can be
reauthorized by board vote right so if
there are projects that are tied to Palm
Elementary School there are a couple
things that can be done first is we
determine what hasn't been spent right
because I I will tell everybody if our
students are in a building we want to
make sure that water's running and that
AC is cooling like that's important I've
had people tell me Matias how could you
improve the 2022 bond program if you
knew this was going to happen. We didn't
know. In 23, the state, we thought the
state would offer support. In 2025, they
did, but only minimally. And throughout
this entire time, we want our kids to
feel safe, supported, and have the
buildings operating. And our staff as
well. So, um, what we do is take the
remaining amount and say, okay, how much
is left? Uh, we would work with our, um,
communities community bond oversight
committee with a framework and say, our
preference is for the dollars to follow
the students. That's always going to be
our preference. Um if the students are
going to bet then we would have to
understand well what is happening at
betas with their money and can this
supplement can it be added because does
it be something different in some cases
not in this case necessarily but in some
cases the school that is receiving is a
modernized facility so you wouldn't need
to spend any money well then the
question becomes can you move it to the
middle school where the students will be
in a couple years or you can move it to
the high school like we really want to
make sure that the money stays in the
vertical in the feeder so that our
students experience that investment in
their academic journey. That's how we
would tackle it. It's a function of the
board. The board takes the vote. Um I
would just give a recommendation, but
that's how it would occur.
>> The next question we have online is from
TA V.
>> That's actually who's raising their hand
right now. So I'll go ahead and do you
want to just ask your question?
Hi, I'm Tanya Vasquez and I have a fifth
grade um graater in at Palm. And so I'm
glad that question came up because it's
kind of alongside the other question
that I have. But according to your
rubric, we were graded a three.
So just seeing that three, how did we
get bumped into a school that's going to
be closed? And let's say the school is
closed, what happens after that? Uh will
you sell palm? And if you do, how much
will the district get?
>> Yeah. So, um, the rubric, uh, as I
communicated, um, throughout the process
was never going to be a school closure
list. It never was. The top 10 that we
we said that over and over again. What
it was meant to communicate is where we
had misalignments in our system, where
we had overenrollment, underenrollment.
There are schools on the top on that
list that are consolidating, but there
are also many others that aren't because
you have to think about the impact of
all the schools around it. So, um,
that's why there wasn't a bumping. It
wasn't like that was a list and somehow
Palm got bumped. It was looking region
by region in our school system,
understanding the kind of overall goals
of the plan, what made sense based on
the fact that we have lots of empty
seats in this part of Austin. And we
have to make a decision regarding um
real estate. At no point along this
journey uh did we ever, you know, make a
conscious decision and say, "Oh, we're
going to close this school because the
land is more valuable or less value."
That wasn't part of this process. Uh
what we do is we go through a process
and we um identify what is community
benefit. Um our trustees in 2019 voted
on an agenda item that said uh housing
is a is a community teacher housing is a
community benefit. community space is a
is a benefit uh and other things. And so
what we're going to do is to bring that
full circle, kind of reintroduce it to
the board and say this is the process
that we're likely to go through. It's
not going to happen without all of
y'all's input. Like we're not going to
go and do something without getting
input from our community. I will say it
has to be balanced because there have
been some communities that say, "Well, I
just want it to be an open park, like
totally open." Well, I mean that's fine,
but there are also kind of this the real
kind of opportunities that exist. If we
could do like a capitalized ground lease
and do housing, right? Bring families
back into the area. That would be a
benefit. So, we're going to go through a
process. I always take the lead from our
community. Sometimes the community wants
to go quicker um and sometimes community
wants to go slower. Uh when we closed
Peas Elementary School, the community
said we want to ensure that students are
in the building. So, we worked with
United Way. We did a contract. Now it's
an early childhood center for Anita Koi.
The conversation was around housing. So
what do we do? We work with our public
facilities corporation which is tied to
our board. And now we have over 600
units being constructed like as we
speak. So we have the ability to do it
together. But I'm going to take y'all's
lead. Uh but at no point did um value or
what it could or couldn't be came up in
the decision-m process.
>> I'm going to go ahead and read the
question that you had, Miss Vosquez,
also just because I think it's an
important one. But the question was,
will the school board consider pausing
the closure of Palm Elementary to allow
the community time to collaborate and
explore solutions that could increase
enrollment and better serve our
students? And so, I know that our
superintendent has kind of shared his
position on on the reasons why we don't
feel it is in the best interest to slow
down. But I also just want to make sure
that everyone kind of understands the
way this plan works is that the
administration makes a recommendation,
which is the we have this draft plan.
There's going to be a revised version of
it Friday. um we present that to the
board and then the board has to make a
determination. They might ask us to make
some other adjustments. They might ask
us to continue listening or refine in
other areas. Um but that so this really
is a question for our board but I think
Matias has kind of described where we
stand in terms of kind of the why about
why we feel that we need to act with a
little bit of urgency.
>> Did you want to add anything to that?
No, I I would just say um we can spend
lots of resources trying to increase
enrollment, but if the kids do not live
in the attendance boundary, you're going
to spend lots of time and energy and we
will see maybe we won't see the gains
that that we would hope to see. We have
this in other parts of the city. I've
been working on this for quite some
time. We really need to think about how
do we support the whole school district.
Um, and so I would tell our board that,
you know, if you slow it down, then
you're going to wait one more year or
two more years and then potentially be
back here in a couple years. I would
argue that the great work that's been
happening here, the things that y'all
have been doing have attracted families,
but we're still less than 50% full,
right? Because the families just don't
live here. And a lot of it had to do
with the flood in 2013. I understand
that. But that is outside of our
control. I I have no control over that.
So, I'm trying to do the best that we
can with the limited opportunities that
we have in front of us with the real
risk of that state kind of above us.
>> We have a question here in Spanish.
According
to your drafts, we uh realize that
you're going to be closing Wedane.
That's school that's real near to to us.
We understand that one of the reasons
you want to close down Palm is because
of the lack of students. Have you
considered having some students from Wed
move to Palm?
>> Yeah. Um so
we haven't uh looked at um moving large
numbers of students from Wedane to Palm
because of the boundary kind of um issue
that I talked about like having schools
cross schools. Uh but we can look at
that. What I will say just to be clear,
Wedane is in a different situation.
uh Wedane um elementary school has
multiple years, three in fact, of not um
making accountability. And what I mean
by not making accountability, there is a
series of D's or Fs that now have
required us AISD to develop a plan that
the state has to approve and they have
so to do that there are certain things
that have to be true. where the students
go to has to be a higher performing
school and and certainly Palmwood would
would qualify. Two, uh that the systems
in place um at the school have to meet
the plan and what that may include is
certain teachers um being required to
have certain number of years of
experience. It could mean um very kind
of clearly articulated and defined um
kind of uh processes throughout the
school year. So it's going to be much
tighter.
Uh and what we have to do is wherever
the majority of students go is where
that turnaround plan exists. Right now
is going to go to the north to Houston
which is being modernized and to the
south to Wedane I mean to Rodriguez. Uh,
so we've thought through that. Again,
not all of them are the same, but that
is why Wedane is is structured that way.
Now, I'm happy to look and see if
there's an opportunity, but I don't know
that we could make it to where all the
students because of what I just
described, but I'm happy to I mean,
that's a response that we can certainly
provide.
>> Okay, I have a question back here and
then I called on this woman there and
there and then I'll get up to the front
again.
>> Hi, my name is Anne Mason. I'm the art
teacher here at Palm. I've been here for
25 years and I noticed that nobody's
addressed the flood issue. Onion Creek
is going to flood again because of all
the construction in Kyle, but Eastern
Park area. What are you going to do if
all of our students are at Bettas and
our parents here can't get across onion
Creek to get their kids when it floods
again? That was an issue in 2015. We
couldn't even bust our kids out of Palm
to get away from the creek. So that is
going to happen again. What what are we
going to do?
>> Yeah. So um so I'm very familiar with
the flooding in 2013 2015 kind of the
the sequence of events that occurred uh
at that time. Um and that's you know
that that's a valid concern. I'm sorry
that's that's a valid concern. Uh so for
us you know when we think about
transition planning because if if Palm
goes to a different location that would
still be true of Bettis, right? families
still want to get to their students at
Bettis. So to us, it's bigger than than
just, you know, any one school. It's how
do we as a school district support our
families in a emergency response
situation where Onion Creek is rising at
a at a very quick rate, which it did in
2015, 2013. Um, and so we went through
that before. Um, we have plans in place.
Um, I can I don't have them I can't
speak to them at the moment. Uh, it's
been a little kind of while since I
revisited them. Uh but as part of the
transition planning, you know, that we
would do together, that's one of the
things that I would make sure is clearly
articulated, communicated, and shared
with our families. Um and so that's I
mean that's the honest truth. That's
exactly what we would do.
>> Next back here.
>> No, because
Sure.
No.
>> My two children almost
I had to
will take my children.
>> So um no that's so what I would say is
we can't make the plan unless we make
the plan with you all together. That's
the honest truth. I'm not going to give
you something that you haven't had a
chance to weigh in on like your lived
experiences to help me understand what
this community needs in order to be
responsive. And the honest truth is we
haven't taken a vote. Like there are
lots of communities that want to plan
and and we want to do things together,
but we haven't gotten to a point where,
you know, we can just go um because of
just where we are in the process. What I
can say is, you know, based on um kind
of all the adjustments and all the
things that have occurred within the um
Onion Creek wershed, which I'm very
familiar with again as well, uh I I
don't um I don't want to I want to
acknowledge the kind of the trauma that
that that occurred in in that space in
that moment and do everything we can to
communicate our response plan, but
there's nothing that I'm going to say
that's going to get anybody to think
that it couldn't happen again, right?
And so I want to be really clear like I
think what this community is looking for
is if this happens again a what are you
going to do right or what what how are
you going to respond and how is it going
to be different than what occurred in
2013 2015 before many of us are here I
cannot and I will never say that I can
guarantee that it's not going to flood
again that's not mean that's not
possible um but that's the reason why so
no we won't I can add more detail to it
I can provide a response to the
questions but as far as the detailed
plan of how it's going to work with this
community accessing betettas. I don't
want to set an expectation that it'll be
fully fleshed out and final before the
21st vote. What I would expect to have
happen is this is the element of the
plan that's going to be considered. This
is the timeline that we're going to work
with community to deliver it. This is
how it's going to be submitted to the
superintendent and the board for
approval. But all of that work requires
you all at the table and right now we're
not even close to a vote. So that's how
it would work. Um and so I I apologize,
but that's that's the the way it'll show
up later. But it'll be done in the
spring semester or shortly after the it
would be done well before the school
year starts.
>> Okay. Yeah. I'm going to ask folks that
we go in order that because we've had
people that have been waiting patiently
and then I'll come back up to y'all.
Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Hi, I'm Karen.
>> Hi, I'm Karen Hunt and I've been here
for 35 years and we were here when there
was a thousand and we had 12 portables.
The portables already there so you can
just bring everybody over anyway. Is
Langford going to be built?
>> Yes.
>> When it when do you propose that that's
going to be built?
>> Because originally it was supposed to be
built. It was going to be two and a half
years. And since they haven't started,
when do you propose that it'll be built?
>> They've started.
>> They have.
>> Oh yeah.
>> We've been by there and there doesn't
look like there's a whole lot going on.
So when you say started
>> so a hole in the ground I mean so just
to be understand how I mean there's a
lot that occurs before
>> you start to see structural steel go up
>> um so they they have started they they
are moving through the process I I don't
want anybody to think there's it's an
active construction site
>> okay but my other question you were
talking about keeping the community
together and keeping all palm together
and moving to PZ then why are some kids
at PDZ then going to be separated and
some going to Langford and some going to
Houston that their community will not be
held together.
>> Thank you for that question. And you can
see if you look at Langford's boundary
as well, it's what we've been calling
feathering, but it's to right shift up
and balance our balance our enrollment
in our schools to where it's more
utilized in a right way. You'll see some
small feathering or or shifts up within
their boundary as well. It's very small,
but you'll see that on the map.
>> Yeah. So, when we talk about communities
going together, if there's a big
disruption, and I would argue a school
closure is a big disruption, I'm going
to do whatever I can to keep the school
together, right? The feathering that
Christine's talking about or the
adjustments boundary by boundary across
the entire sta city, there's hundreds
and hundreds of those occurring, like
minor adjustments. I I don't want um we
we can't keep every community together
or else we would never have a boundary
change, right? That's just the honest
truth. So, uh that's why you're going to
see some adjustments like that. We are
making refinements. In the last two and
a half weeks since we or three weeks
since we've released the draft, we've
been making lots of changes, making
adjustments to acknowledge that, hey, we
probably didn't have to do it quite that
way. You know, we can probably fit them
in even though it doesn't quite meet our
goal. And that's okay. And we're making
those changes. uh if that's if we hear
from the Bettis community that that's
something that that is a concern or a
strain, we will make the adjustment if
it doesn't create another consider
another change downstream like adding a
split at a middle school or adding a
split at a high school which which does
happen if every one of these changes has
an impact downstream. So that that's why
>> we have a question back here.
>> Yeah. So um I'm actually I'm actually
hit on two fronts with this one. I have
a child that goes to Palm and then my
son goes to bed. So they're both getting
closed, right? That's your proposed
plan. You spoke on alignment earlier and
so my question is this. If you drive and
nobody wants to move here, if you drive
three minutes down the road down
Thaxton, there's brand new houses and
apartments popping up all over the
place. So why isn't the realignment done
with Blazer, who's probably overpop
populated since they have an
intermediate school already, done to
adjust what enrollment would be
happening here at Palm. and you grew up
on William Cannon. So the south 78745
and 44 would be familiar to you. Yet a
historical schools like Palm and Bedric
are your choice to close.
>> So the first thing I would say is um I
don't take closures lightly by any means
and we had a conversation here about
boundary changes from Palm to Blazer and
some of the challenges we have just
because of where Blazier is. It is so
far north in its attendance boundary and
Palm is so far south in its attendance
boundary where to capture the number of
students that we would need, you quickly
get into a space where Palm's boundary
would actually include Blazier
Elementary School. Now, again, I'm going
to go look at it and see what
opportunity exists, but we're 50% full
here. So, you'd have to pick up hundreds
and hundreds of kids to get back to a
balanced, you know, school that that can
be supported for for years to come.
That's so we're going to look at that
and we have looked at it but you know I
will commit to looking at it again as
far as betich goes I know betichek well
um
this is one of those ones that's really
really tough because there's an excess
of middle school seats in south Austin
between covington Mendes Pettes O'Henry
Lively and Betachch um Betachch also
just right wrong or indifferent from the
state's perspective has three Fs they
have they have an accountability
Historically, they have accountability
chain that has to be broken. If we do
not break that accountability chain,
there is a real state intervention risk,
meaning the state comes in, right? You
know what that means? They take over the
board. There's it's that level of thing.
It's happening right now in Fort Worth.
I'm not going to let that happen. We are
committed to having a presence and
reinvisioning what BetCh is. Betch's
been around for a long time. It's an
important part of that community. I
recognize that in the plan we talk about
restarting betichek um you know but I
can't do that uh without some type of
change because right now the pressure is
just you have too many seats and you
have the accountability risk and so I'm
I'm really sorry that that's happening.
It's never my intention to impact a
family and to this type this degree. I
know it's happening. We're trying to
figure out what we can do to support
that transition. We know most of the
students are going to go to Covington.
Some will go to Pareas and some will go
to Lively. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. So,
>> yeah. So, so that so that's the one of
the things that we look at is um where
where are they where are they headed and
then what changes have occurred to date,
right? And what I will tell you is the
state of Texas has to accept our plans.
Um as you probably know that we went
through a change at Poretta recently. uh
this school year is different than last
school year and so um the turnaround
plan and given its proximity so Prett is
is kind of similar to way Palm is where
it's on the southeast corner of the
school district so there's nothing to
the east which means that you'd have to
make all those students only go in one
direction the reason Betachch because we
looked at that the reason Betachch does
work is because I can have multiple
schools absorb the number of students if
you go the other way then you only have
u Mendes to the north and uh Betachch to
the west and it doesn't work like it's
too much. And so the only reason that
Betachch is the school is because it
happens to be surrounded by other
schools that have capacity. So so you
have to like that all of this comes into
play. Um I I know it's not the answer
you wanted to hear, but that's that's
the honest truth, right? If I go the
other way, it doesn't work the same. It
doesn't work.
>> Next, we have a person right here. Was
there anyone else? If you want to raise
your hand, I can call on you next.
>> Hi, I'm Judy. Uh, my baby's in the fifth
grade. I just want to know, have you
counted how many kids you're going to
lose by closing this? Like mine is in
the fifth grade. Half of his kids class
is not even going to a public school.
We're all going to a charter school.
They have siblings. They are going to go
to that charter school because they
don't want to go to Perez. Have y'all
thought about that?
>> So, um, we've thought about a lot of
these things that as well. the the
question becomes so is doing nothing
like we we've been working like you all
been doing great work here. I mean y'all
been y'all been doing great work. So why
has a why are we not there from an
overall utilization perspective? So I
don't want to sit here and say that that
if we put all the resources and
everything in place that it's somehow
going to grow when we haven't seen that
and there aren't students that live
here. So, let me let me let me I just
want to talk about that point because I
want to get to a point where all of our
schools have the resources needed to
support their students. Period. Whether
you're at PCON springs, you know, if
you're at, you know, Blackshere,
wherever you are. And right now, my my
position is if we have those resources
and we have incredible teachers and the
student and the culture and climate
continue to move in the direction that
they have, we will attract students
back. I always want families to do
what's best for their students. I do
believe that Austin ICT is the best
option, but I also understand that
there's going to be transitions and
families going to be make a different
decision. I hope not to make them, but I
can't quantify what that is. I can't say
that it's this percent or this percent.
What I can tell you is that other school
districts have gone through
consolidations in the state of Texas and
they've seen, you know, fairly minimal
changes in in enrollment. Um, you know,
again, because I've heard someone say,
"Well, everybody's going to go." Well, I
I I you know, I don't I don't know how
to respond to that. question.
>> Why does it take y'all if a school is an
F, why does it take y'all three years
before y'all do something about it?
>> So, when you say y'all, you're talking
about the AISD, right? So, um what I
would first say is, you know, disruption
matters. It has a huge impact on this
system. Now, you talk about 3Fs being
23, 24, and 25. Well, the 23
accountability well so this version of
the administration and the board came
together in the end of that year, right?
And so you think about what have we
done? We've done a lot. A, we went from
about 72% uh teacher um uh retention
rate to 88%. We had uh 92% 88% um
staffing rates. Now we're at 97 and a
half percent. The first year I came in,
we hired over 20 principles. Now we
hired, you know, five. And so when you
went through superintendent after
superintendent after superintendent and
then that turned over the executive
team, that turned over the principles,
that turned over the teachers, like
you're going to have that type of
impact. So I agree with you. We should
have done more earlier. There's no
doubt. But I don't want anybody to leave
here thinking that we haven't moved the
system in the last two and a half years,
right? We have instructional coaches
where we didn't have them before.
Content interventions that are coming
into system now. We have an aligned
curriculum for the first time. Instead
of having, you know, 15 different
curriculum and then having students with
high mobility rates go to one school and
have one experience, go another school,
have a different experience. We don't
have that. That hurts our black and
brown kids, right? It just does. And so
where we are now with we're seeing
improvements in early literacy, early
numeracy. We've seen every metric that
we measure moving in the right
direction. So yes, I I wish we would
have
decisions before me I can't speak to.
Um, we need to own the moment, make
difficult decisions, support our babies,
and and move forward together. Uh, I
promise you I will be responsive. I
promise you I will do what's required no
matter how hard it is. This is hard. Um,
but I I can't speak to why something did
or didn't happen years ago. What I can
tell you is we were not set up for that
type of success. Um, but I think we are
now moving forward.
>> Okay. I have see a few people who have
spoken already. Is there anyone if you
could raise your hand if you haven't
gotten a chance to speak and you would
like to
>> raise your hand?
>> Did you have your hand up?
>> Oh, I'm sorry.
>> Anyone else that hasn't spoken? Just
going to give one more call.
>> Okay. Then I'll come back to you and I
know that you said you wanted to speak
and then back to you.
>> So, I mean, I'm just going to be
hard-headed. It's it's hard. I'm not
getting the the answer that I want about
Blazer besides getting into Blazer being
back, you know, Blazier being part of
taking some of their kids. I don't you
you know you say they're a good school.
I mean we know they're a good school.
Everybody knows they're a good school.
Those parents know they're a good
school.
>> I think all of our I mean I love
>> No, I know. I mean we know our school's
good. I don't have to say that. But what
I'm saying is I I wish you would go over
there and fight for us to say we're
going to have to cut
>> your boundary. It's gonna back up to
you'll probably be right here, but
you're gonna go to to Palm and Palm's a
great school and because you're talking
about disruption and and bringing down
disruption, but if you would if you
could give us some of those kids, give
us 400 kids, we'll take them. If you
gave us those kids to come over here,
then we don't have to go to Bettis and
Bettis doesn't have to split up. Keep
Bettis where they are because right now
you're moving some kids to Houston from
Bettis, right?
>> No. No.
>> So, Wedane is going to Houston and
Rodriguez. That's what I think you
heard.
>> So, then they could stay there. So no
one has to they don't have to move
around and it would leave less
disruption. I don't understand I don't
understand why is this such a big deal
to cut them. How many kids do they have
at at Blazer?
>> They have over,200 kids. Why why can't
they just someone go in there? Why can't
you go in there and say look as a
community like you're telling us here as
a community we're making this plan.
Nobody in this community I think asked
for Palmer to be closed and go to bed.
So that was not a community decision.
But why can't you go over there and say
this is going to make sense. We are
teaching exactly what they are teaching
over there. We don't have three years of
FS over here. Bring some of those kids
over here so that we could stay here in
this area. It just seems so simple to to
go on to say other things of um you know
this is what we need to do. This is the
best. You haven't I feel like you're
just selling it. You haven't even said
this is what could happen at the end.
But but we know I don't under you have
to make it clear. I don't I the salesman
talk of th this is going to be good. I
we sat down and we thought about this,
we thought about that, but have you I
mean, have you talked to us really? You
know, those questions I I mean, we put
in a lot of questions and there was like
seven that came up. You know, give us
the answer. Tell us really is it going
to be the end of the world if we go into
Blazers neighborhood. Is it going to be
the end of the world? Is it going to be
hard for those parents just to come over
here to drive wow three more minutes
than for parents who like our parent
over here who lives right around the
street down the street and walks every
day that won't be able to do that with
his child anymore. How is that okay for
us, you know, and not okay for them?
>> Yeah. Well, um I'm not trying to be a
salesman. I'm trying to communicate the
urgency around us doing something so
that we're not here talking about why we
have these pressures a year from now,
two years from now, three years from
now. Like I to me um I I want to really
communicate like these are real risks
that we're managing budget risk keeping
staff and so it's it's not that I'm
trying to sell. I'm just trying to
communicate the urgency around this. We
have to do something differently than
what we've been doing for the last many
decades. I have no problem. I you I I
will make hard decisions. I will go in.
I will assess. I will look at
opportunities and I will talk to the
communities and I will be straight up
with them about what I think is best. I
will tell you that when it comes to some
of the things that we identified as um
kind of goals or maybe strategies that
we wanted to explore as part of this, we
you know that creates challenges when
you get to kind of these really really
tight spots, right? So I I have no
problem going and looking at that again.
I just be really honest about what that
may introduce. One of the things we talk
about is splitting vertical teams. I I
know that Blazer goes to is assigned to
Pareetas. You know, these schools over
here are assigned to different ele. So,
we have to recognize what does that look
like? How does a high school feeding get
p get split? These are the things that
that we talked about in in aligning
feeder patterns. If it's going to create
a conflict there, I got to talk to our
trustees, talk to the community like,
hey, this is something we could do, but
all these other things are going to be
not compromised, but they're kind of in
exchange for it. And so, that's just
what that's the honest truth. like I
have no problem. We were going to look
at it. I'll I will assess again. Um the
other thing that we run into is total
number of seats in an area. So let's say
that we go ahead and pull students from
Blazer. We're still going to have the
same number of seats over the total
number of available seats in the area,
right? Because we didn't get rid of we
didn't take anything out. We just moved
them around. And so someone mentioned
prek not being there. Yeah. So UPH house
has the the prek students that go to
Blazier. um you know and they made those
decisions years ago. So you know if we
did something different and then prek
moved back in then does blazer does you
up house close like so that those are
the things that I want to be really
honest about that I have to make sure we
tackle no I I we did explore it I am
committed to going back I will have a
difficult conversation I know that
community I I I will I will do what's
required to support the whole there's no
doubt I I and so I I want you to know
like
>> they get that guarantee like if I'm a
parent because
1200 kids
for us
and that's true. Here we are getting
and it just seems like nothing. It's
like
except for the district
go and they just their boundaries. My
daughter had to move from going down
this way to take her kids to going down
And there was no it was done. It was
said and done and I don't understand why
I can't.
>> So So one of the things that dripping
does is they created a process where
they reevaluate every couple years. We
don't do that. We're going to do that
because I don't want to be here in five
years, six years. This is too painful.
It's brutal. Right? When communities get
set in their boundaries because they
feel like they're never going to change
and we have to set the expectation.
families move, developments grow. You
know, floods happen, right? You have to
expect that every so many years we're
going to revisit it. That expectation I
want to set as long as I'm here, I'm
going to do it. Um, but I'm happy to
have that conversation, but that's why
Dripping Springs is able to do it
because they've set the expectation with
the community. And most of the schools
are newer. We are an old school
district. We're 144 years old. Dripping
Springs is barely 80, barely 70. I mean,
so all the things I mean, we're like,
it's in our bones that we're trying to
address. Um, so, so that's newer school
districts tend to have that process and
procedure already in place. Old mature
school districts don't do it so great.
>> Okay. So, we have about seven minutes
left and we do have a hard stop because
we have a community meeting after this,
a virtual one actually. Um, but I know
that I called on you um you in the black
shirt and then this gentleman had his
hand up and that will be the the time
that we have.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> Mine's a staffing question. So, at our
last meeting with talent strategy,
>> talent strategy,
>> they they said if like 40% of the
students go to a new campus, 40% of the
staff should go to that campus. So, I'm
wondering if 100% of Palm students are
going to Bettis, should 100% of us just
get moved over there? Is that how it's
going to work?
>> Yeah. So, um, one of the things I would
say is if it's a larger population, it's
going to be a larger group of teachers
for sure. Matias, I want to just
clarify. It's not what percentage of
your school is going. It's what
percentage you make up of the school.
So, what what percentage of Pettz's new
enrollment does Palm make up? So, if
you're 50% of theirs or if you're 60% of
your 40 um I think we could probably get
it for you in a moment.
>> We have it in the sheet. Yeah.
>> So, it's like
>> So, if it's 50% then about 50% roughly.
>> No, no, not it's 50% of the total staff
because they're different student
different school populations. So you
take if if we combine the schools and
it's 5050 right well 50% of the total
new population is is palm then I would
expect 50% of the teaching allocations
at betas to be represented by palm faces
right
>> so if if it's a if it's a 100% of a
school and the the new school is much
bigger we have some of those where the
receiving school is like 500 and the
school coming in is 150 right so in that
case it's closer to like you know 20 22%
something like
Now, that's just a rule of thumb, like
you know, our our our principles, we've
talked to them, we've had conversations,
they know we want familiar faces. We
want our community to know that we are
being really intentional and our staff
to feel supported. So, that's where we
would go. But that's kind of a rule of
thumb of how we're trying to tackle it,
just to make sure we don't ever shy off
or get too deviate too far from our
values. Like, let's say that we didn't
do that and all of a sudden that
principal started hiring a whole bunch
of people that weren't Palm staff. That
would be a non-starter for me.
50% of
>> 50% of the staff at Bettis would be Palm
staff. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Not 50 because I mean the
math it's it could work both ways.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I think this Well,
>> yeah. So, I mean that's that's there
there's going to be you know like there
we are going through a staffing plan for
each transition period. Um, you know,
it's not always going to be like clear
50, you know, precise. Um, but every
time students go, right, they don't come
in perfectly neat 22 size blocks, but
we're going to have to add staff, right?
And and the rule should be, and it is
going to be that any new allocation
needs to be drawn from the staff here
first. Period. Period. That's also true
of custodial staff. It's also true of
food service staff. I mean, everybody,
right? Those are all faces and and
supports for our students. That's how we
operate.
Yeah, 100%.
>> Yeah. Well, special areas. So, essential
areas. Okay.
>> Yeah. So, essential areas is going to be
um very similar depending. So, let's say
that the larger student population now
um kind of releases another allocation
for PE, right? Which could easily
happen. In that case, that's what would
happen. It would be the P. I mean,
that's how we would do it. When it comes
to front office staff, um I'd have to,
you know, that one's a little bit more
difficult because most elementary
schools have the same allocations no
matter how big or small the school is.
Uh so if there was a vacancy, we'd
obviously want to pull here for sure. Um
we also have um areas where the new
students would actually allocate their
assistant principal. Well, of course,
you would want that person to be the
assistant principal of the previous
school. So, we're being very
intentional. Um we also are being, you
know, it's important that our principles
are talking to each other. We set the
stage for it. we have these expectations
and we we execute the plan. What I don't
want to do is to ever create an
environment where families or staff
outside of the receiving school are
considered before the receiving school.
Like that's not going to happen.
>> Okay. And this is going to be our last
question and then I'm going to go over
the timeline one more time.
>> All right. So you're talking projections
and census and everything, right? You're
closing palm down. Blazers already
busting at the seams. What are they
going to do in 10 years from now when
Slaughter Lane blows up on population
with all the new families moving in?
You're still going to need this school
to remain open to offset the influx of
the new families coming in. This school
will be a va v vital entity for this
neighborhood and the growing
neighborhood coming.
>> Yeah. So um
so south of Slaughter Lane, Goodn Night
Ranch expansion, I mean there are
thousands of homes as you as you
mentioned going up, right? Uh you think
about kind of the way Aikens and Pareas
are or are kind of situated there. Uh
there is a plan for investment in years
to come like way down the road for
another elementary school way down south
because geographic proximity matters.
like you we never want to be in a
position where we're busing kids across
town, right? And and we will make
adjustments when it's adjacent schools,
but once you begin to move too far and
all of a sudden you're saying, "Hey, to
make this work, I got to put kids in a
bus for 30 minutes to go south, like
that, that is not what I want to
support. I don't believe our trustees
want to support that." Um, so we do look
at projections. Right now, our plans do
consider these moves. Um, you know, I'm
happy to go back and and explore it and
and make adjustments, but yes, it it
does consider that expansion of the
Goodn Night Ranch in Southeast Austin.
Uh, and also kind of what happens to
Casey Elementary School, what happens to
like all the schools including Casser
because there's going to be movement
like all the way around in that area.
Blazier does have a large area. Um, and
what if you could go back in time that I
mean, not that you could, but Blazer
should have been located much farther
south. That's just the honest truth. Um,
you know, I wasn't here. that was a long
time ago, but that's what's created this
like conject like conject like stress in
the system in this one geographic area.
>> Okay, thank you so much everyone. I'm
just going to as a reminder go over the
timeline. Um so we're in phase three of
this process. Um we do have up came out
this is a new um opportunity that was
added. So there well we actually tonight
have our district-wide consolidation
meeting. It's virtual, so you can um get
on the Zoom um with us at 5:30 if you
would like. Um but then we also to on
Wednesday night, our board has added a
board workshop and that's where we're
going to talk to the board about this
draft plan. We're going to talk about
some of the ideas that have come from
the community um to see the feasibility
of some of those. Um, and then that
draft plan, um, the revisions to the
draft plan are going to be go live this
Friday, and that will be discussed at
next Thursday's board meeting, November
6th. Um, and then the final version
we're going to be asking our board to
vote on will be the November 20th. So, I
just wanted to remind everyone of those
dates. Um, just wanted to say thank you
to everybody um, for all of your
feedback. And I hope that I know that
not every answer was the answer that was
that was what you were looking for, but
I hope you did hear that we will be
looking at and exploring the ideas that
you have shared. We have been doing so
and cataloging all of those comment
cards. There's still time. Thank you.
There's still time to um submit the
comment cards through tomorrow. So, if
there's any new ideas that you thought
of, go ahead and get them in there um by
the end of day tomorrow. Did you want to
say any last words?
>> No, just um thank you for the time this
evening. Um, I know it's it's it's it's
a bit big disruption. Um, I'm sorry that
we're going through this. I am committed
to doing it as thoughtfully as we
possibly can given what we're faced with
here. Um, so thank you for the time.
Like we will refine, we will update. I'm
committed. I will go and and do what I
need to do. And I I hope that um you
stay with us in this process because
your input absolutely will inform our
final plan and also um transition. So,
thank you and I appreciate all of y'all.